So many couples wanted to be married on Sunday, the first day of legal homosexual marriage in New York City,...
...that local officials announced a lottery to determine eligibility.
New York City Council Speaker Christine Quinn, herself openly gay,...
...witnessed the first two ceremonies.
She says the same-sex marriage law supports equality.
Margie Phelps minced no words to denounce same-sex marriage as a crime against God.
She and other Christians from the Westboro Baptist Church in Topeka, Kansas...
...came halfway across the country to say marriage is defined by Holy Scripture.
David Schwartz, an Orthodox Jew, believes every human being has free choice and the power to rule over their desires.
He considers homosexual desire to be wrong.
Gella Soloman, also a Jew, rejects that definition of marriage,...
...as well as the notion that marriage is reserved for the procreation of children.
Douglas Robinson and his partner of 25 years, Michael Elsasser,...
...were in the first group to be married in Manhattan.
Robinson says the United States allows religious views to coexist with what he believes is a civil right of same-sex marriage.
Margie Phelps believes God will punish New York City for permitting what she believes to be moral decay.
Meanwhile, Nevin Cohen and Daniel Hernandez showed off their marriage certificates.
But they said they are not going on a honeymoon.
They say they need to be at work on Monday.
Peter Fedynsky, VOA News, New York.